hey everyone before we get into today's
video I want to issue a quick trigger
warning the video that I will be
reviewing today does contain some
disordered eating tips tricks and
recommendations so if this sounds like
something that may be triggering to you
I suggest not watching hey everyone i'm
abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen in
today's video I want to talk about a
recent YouTube video that has gained a
lot of attention and it's actually been
sent to me by like 20 different fans of
mine so this is by HRH collections
alexandra pierce and it's titled fine
then go be fat and leave me alone
does anybody have any vodka for this
okay so before I get into the video
let's talk about Alexandra and her
channel in general so Alexandra is a
beauty blogger and youtuber that has
over 150,000 subscribers on YouTube and
over 100,000 followers on Instagram so
it's safe to say that the girl has a lot
of responsibility and influence most of
Alexandra's Instagram consists of her
fashion products particularly jewelry
however she periodically dives into the
Wellness space and talks about her
journey to becoming skinny those are her
words friends not mine
in fact she's got an entire story series
on her Instagram titled skinny but I'll
get back to that little later Alexander
has gained a lot of popularity for her
controversial rants and today's video is
no exception so today I want to chat
about some of the most problematic
elements of this video to save you from
having to watch it yourself you're
welcome issue number one is that her
diet recommendations sound very much
aligned with the criteria for disordered
eating now I am NOT a psychiatrist or a
psychologist and I'm absolutely not
formally diagnosing her with anything
but it's my professional opinion as a
dietician that a lot of Alexandra
statements do not reflect a healthy
relationship with food in fact if you
check out Netta's website page further
warning signs and symptoms of an eating
disorder I see a lot of those checked
off boxes let's take a look at some of
the most problematic statements in this
video first of all you shouldn't be
eating
if you're trying to lose weight do not
eat a straight like kitchen is [ __ ]
closed after eight know if you go to
your dying I told you I've showed you
guys what the [ __ ] options are if
you're not block you stop it's ten
calorie jello it's [ __ ] like string
beans string beans or something and like
two cherry tomatoes like I look upon a
jalapeno like a [ __ ] pickle like a
like a tiny pickle like something like
that like no you're not hitting anymore
I'm also going to talk about going to
bed hungry you guys are gonna kill me I
don't give a [ __ ] and by the way I'm not
have a hold a gun to your head and I'm
not like if you don't I think you look
like something I do like an influence
that you shouldn't be saying thing is
that like first leg not that died from
it you're gonna look better so shut up
is there more is there have to be more
is there let me tell me tell me how much
more have to listen to so like if you're
dying then you can have a ten calorie
package jello like I am totally aware
that some people feel they need to have
some kind of guidelines or structure
with their eating and that is totally
okay that is one thing but alexander is
actively telling you to ignore your
body's screaming hunger cues which are
designed to help you fuel your body
right I'm getting mad oh my god
obviously this type of eating is not
sustainable and it feels pretty damn
miserable if you ask me I mean your body
is literally begging you to eat to the
point that you're excited about eating
some string beans and two cherry
tomatoes that is a good sign that you
should respect those cues and give it
the fuel that's asking for before you do
some serious metabolic and psychological
damage oh okay
next okay what you should do it says it
says you should get right back on track
except that it happened and move on
understand that human beings aren't
perfect right that's what it says you
should do what you shouldn't do is this
beat yourself up beat yourself up for
being human do cardio as a punishment to
make up for it restrict calories or
meals if if I was a cartoon and there
would be like red my face would be red
and I'd be like steam coming out of my
ears okay that's me right now leave bad
advice let me tell you what you should
do I don't listen I hate
what you should do I said what you
shouldn't do you shouldn't beat yourself
up over being a bad human no beat
yourself up for being human what what
does that have to do with [ __ ] up if
you [ __ ] up and you don't want to like
[ __ ] up you're like progress then you
should do something to rectify that
situation like just because you don't
feel sorry for yourself doesn't mean
that it's gonna like go away like you
did 10 ik so make sure you [ __ ] and
do something to like get back to like
rectify that damage so on and it's a do
cardio as a punishment to make up for it
what's wrong with that absolutely if you
head over if you go over your calories
one day go on a run what's wrong with
that this is wrong on so many levels
okay first of all you're allowed to be a
human being and enjoy food but second
you shouldn't have to treat yourself
like because you decided to enjoy a
little cake in fact I would argue that
you're being kind to yourself by
allowing all foods to fit into your diet
but Alexandra here is telling her
viewers that they need to fix the damage
that they've done this is diet culture
101 you eat something enjoyable you feel
like crap about it then you go on a diet
then you cave and you eat it and the
cycle repeats itself over and over and
over again instead what if we actually
enjoyed the food on occasion and didn't
feel bad about it after like I've talked
about before it would lose its power and
appeal and we wouldn't feel the need to
overdo it and binge I'm sorry but this
is a whole lot of wrong oh to bed hungry
and then you wake up like you wake up
way thinner honestly and you wake up
like with a flatter stomach you wake up
I just wake up feeling so much better
like when I was heavy I used to go to
bed [ __ ] full like I would eat so I
like couldn't eat anymore almost like I
just be I like Grey's after dinner one
of the best things in this my weight
loss thing that I've done is to go to
bed hungry not like starving so like if
I had dinner at like 7:00 like
and then have like some random stupid
like vegetable snacks or whatever a
gelatin calorie jell-o after 8 you know
then I went to bed I would basically go
to bed kind of hungry and then you wake
up in the morning and I could feel like
my bones which I love I know it whatever
not like anorexic okay I'm so much
[ __ ] executor saw me like I feel like
oh my god we could pull you back you
like rather than feeling stomach I felt
like you know my pelvic bone um hip bone
like on the bed you know what I mean I
let my rib on the bed and like I'm not
trying to like be like really really
[ __ ] skinny I don't I can't ever get
really skinny like I'm not like that
cuz I love food too much um but you
don't I mean I like like that when I
don't wake up feeling like that like
that I feel like I know I ate too much
the day before to be honest okay this
makes me like really really sad first of
all feeling your bones should never ever
be a goal it's obviously a sign that
your body is losing too much of its
muscle and fat which is needed for so
many important biological functions but
also waking up ravenously hungry is
assignment you didn't eat enough before
bed and that your blood sugar levels are
so low that your body's literally
begging you for fuel also a lot of the
time when we wake up our body may look a
little bit different because we're
actually dehydrated and any kind of
toned look tends to go away once we
drink some water and eat some food like
this is not a state that is healthy for
most people to maintain unless you want
to end up in the hospital for
dehydration all right now speaking of
bones my other bone to pick is that she
speaks as if calories are really all
that matters now with all of the
advances we've seen in nutrition science
I'm really annoyed that we're reverting
back to this concept that calories are
king let's take a look at some examples
what I'm talking about is popcorn in
general people think it's like a healthy
alternative and I'm telling you it's not
it's like the devil is probably as bad
an avocado is help calories wise and I
don't want to hear anything on here like
if you guys are gonna sit here and try
to tell me calories don't work then
you're been honestly there's something
wrong with your brain because you can
see I don't know how much I've lost
I'm guessing like 20 to 30 pounds I'm
guessing 25 maybe that's what I'm
guessing okay so if calories calorie
counting doesn't work that apparently
like I know I just want to eat from
nothing right nothing okay guys stop it
now like don't talk to me about it but
I'm doctor now doesn't matter okay it's
all about low calories I told you I
could be [ __ ] 12 or I can eat a
thousand calories of Oreos or a thousand
calories of [ __ ] broccoli and I would
be the same thing she's angry anyway so
Alexander says that she can eat a
thousand calories of Oreos or a thousand
calories of broccoli and still have the
same weight loss outcome now just to be
clear calories do matter overeating or
under eating calories can both have
effects on her health and cause changes
to our weight however that doesn't mean
that we should equate eating Oreos to
eating broccoli just because in certain
portions there calorically equal the
good thing about eating a diet high in
vegetables is the nutrient and fiber
content
fiber helps to fill us up and keeps us a
shaded they're also pretty low in
calories so it'd be very hard to overdo
it you'd have to eat a lot of broccoli
but in comparison Oreos are low in
nutrients and high in sugar this causes
a big up/down effect on our blood sugar
which can leave us feeling pretty hungry
pretty fast so even if we only ate a
thousand calories of Oreos now we would
be hungry for more calories far sooner
than had we had a thousand calories of
broccoli so no Alexandra calories may
matter but they're not created equal
still a lot of calories okay let me show
you how much you get in this [ __ ]
bag 480 calories it's not even worth it
it's not worth it look at this oh my
gosh oh my God look at this little baby
[ __ ] Bowl this is 80 calories of
[ __ ] nothing in here it's nothing
first of all I was like there's not time
to seize it I swear to God
look like you got it you saw popcorn
probably three handfuls that's all you
get
three handfuls of this 480 calories okay
it's not worth it I would much rather
have 100 calorie pack of Doritos at
least you get probably was it 13 know
how many color is I need for 140
calories I think you got like I don't
want to say is everyone fun come after
me if I say like you get 10 chips
but no getting tips big thing so I can't
even say it
I can't defend myself because once this
is up I can't speak you know what I mean
but all I'm saying is I would rather
have $100 of Dorito something I really
genuinely like and sit there and savor
them then this little [ __ ] piss ass
bowl of plain popcorn is so depressing
she's so angry I don't understand how
anyone can be so angry at popcorn just
popcorn so Alexander and I can agree and
disagree on this one first of all why is
80 calories paint it to be such a big
deal like in the grand scheme of a
typical 2,000 calorie diet 80 calories
is no big deal in fact it's negligible
at best
also popcorn is the best but I'm cool
with this disagreement because what I
agree with you on is the idea of
choosing foods that you actually love
and savoring them a lot of people try to
replace their unhealthy snacks with
guilt free diet options and the common
issue is that they feel so unsatisfied
after that and they start craving the
other snack that they actually want so
let's say that you wanted Doritos but
you would only allow yourself to have
popcorn so you'd eat your small portion
of popcorn not be satisfied then you
need a handful of cereal and then nuts
and then grapes and then cheese and you
still not be satisfied and then you
would cave and have an entire family
size bag of Doritos and by that time you
know you've really eaten beyond your
physical needs
so most people would actually be better
off if they just enjoyed the cookie or
the bag of chips or whatever it is that
they really really want without the
guilt so that they could move on stop
thinking about it and stop putting it on
a pedestal
having said that intuitive eating is not
just about eating too
all day every day because you like them
it's about neutralizing the power of
Doritos so you're less likely to overeat
them meanwhile it's about incorporating
some gentle nutrition into your day and
then taking notes about how certain
foods make you feel and help satisfy you
so popcorn for example is a whole grain
and the fiber may keep you more
satisfied than a handful of Doritos if
you don't like popcorn then obviously
it's not a great choice for you but
these nutrition considerations are also
part of being kind to your body so next
is the claim that skinny people don't
eat and they're lying if they say they
do oh my god you guys don't they don't
actually eat right actually don't
[ __ ] eat there's no way in hell that
skinny very very skinny girls eat it
just like impossible it's they're boring
so I'm like you know which look very
very lucky gene typically they actually
start myself that probably while I would
not be surprised if some influencers do
misrepresent their eating patterns on
social media it's not fair to say that
all thin people are lying I would also
suggest that it's not fair to say that
all fat people eat poorly our bodies
naturally come in all different shapes
and sizes some people are born with
larger bodies while others are born with
smaller ones and research also shows
that genetics play a huge role in the
natural fate of our body size and how we
metabolize calories here's the thing
though
it's not like the Mendelian way of
inheritance where you may have brown
eyes or blue eyes depending on which
gene is dominant or recessive it appears
that there are actually well over 50
different genes that are associated with
how we store fat so it's not a
black-and-white science what we do know
however is that some genes may be
affected by our food choices more than
others so for example one common gene
associated with fat mass is called the
FTO gene research has shown that people
with an FTO variant are more likely to
have a higher BMI what's more earlier
research suggests that having this
variant can also change the way we
metabolize and store energy meaning that
some people may store fat much quicker
and in greater amounts than others in
addition to this there is some research
that suggests prenatal nutrition plays a
role in our body's ability
to metabolize food so it seems that a
fetus's nutritional status can actually
alter molecules that affect genes that
are dedicated to metabolism and as a
result lead to a higher or lower level
of fat storage later on in life finally
there is a growing amount of evidence
that tells us that our gut microbiome
affects our weight as well so it seems
that a less diverse microbiome is
associated with a higher body weight
while a more diverse microbiome is
linked to lower body weights regardless
of caloric intake this honestly is just
scratching the surface and I haven't
even touched on the social determinants
of healthier and of course some people
can manipulate their body weight
somewhat with behavioral changes despite
their DNA but considering the diet
failure rate is 95 percent calories in
and calories out is far from a perfect
sign and my final issue here is the
valuing of thinness over health you guys
know I always say being thin does not
equal healthy just like being in a
larger body also does not equal being
unhealthy it's pretty clear that
Alexandra needs some consistent
validation from her followers just tell
her that she looks thin I mean let's
just take a quick look at some of this
footage here people legitimately well
first of all people this one kinds like
said things so that I was photoshopping
my pictures like I swear to god I'm not
gonna show me pictures it's a
combination of having lost a lot of
weight yes but also knowing my angles
you guys don't always admitted that like
I know my angles but did you guys see
this [ __ ] photo I look like a [ __ ]
I look like like an exclamation point in
this picture like can we talk about this
admit you're not blocked it's like half
that half you guys are blocked down here
I understand how you like unfortunately
you can see but like I'll have a guide
down exclamation point in this [ __ ]
photo like I don't think an eye like a
capital eye I look at like a small in
the lowercase L like there's nothing to
me I couldn't believe it like the whole
thing looks photoshopped as [ __ ] like um
I um I die over these comments are so
funny like you guys make me [ __ ]
laugh I was dying like somebody said how
big that couple it's next to Alex
I see a black sharpie aligned with the
head okay BRB gonna go buy a whole
section of limousine to get this bod you
guys are so funny well done alex is so
thin she can look at the peephole what
she can forget the peephole with both
eyes so what's that I love you but being
skinny is out by yourself shut up leave
me alone like what a stupid comment I
love you Abbi skinny is so out okay
well then go me fat leave me alone um so
yeah this is like really hard to watch
because it's really sad to see someone
whose whole identity is so bound up in
the validation that she gets from her
strangers from followers people who
don't actually really know her and how
upset it makes her when she doesn't get
it it's honestly really hard to watch
another woman just hand over her power
and self-worth so easily
honestly I fully get it you know you
work in the public eye and people don't
know you but they feel like they have
the right to say horrible horrible
things to you and even though it
shouldn't matter sometimes it's still
like really hurts so I I totally can
relate on that level I also fully
understand and appreciate the desire to
lose weight even if currently that's
kind of out of vogue or taboo to talk
about however what I do want to flag is
that there are a number of
recommendations that Alexandra makes and
strategies that she employs that tell me
that her pursuit of thinness may come at
the expense of her health we know that
even at the best of times
dieting fails the dieting habits that
Alexandria's suggesting specifically
feel so aggressively restrictive I mean
she talks about the need to go to bed so
hungry to the point that you feel like
you can't stand it anymore so that you
can wake up thinner with a flat stomach
and your hipbones kind of sinking into
the mattress that is horribly triggering
Alexandria's recommendations have
nothing to do with making more
nutritious choices
rather they're about severe restriction
and denying your body to energy that it
needs and is begging for I am 100%
supportive of other people's health and
wellness journeys even if they include
weight loss desires but this is
downright dangerous we've talked about
the impact of set point theory and that
severe restriction is often going to
result in a slowed metabolism and I am
genuinely concerned that when Alexandria
gives up this pursuit because who can
sustain starvation that long the impact
on our metabolism is going to be so
severe that she is going to be
completely completely devastated gaining
weight with age and different life
stages is totally normal but in my
experience the people who see huge jumps
in weight gain are the people who are
severely restricting calories and then
who go back to eating normally again
Finny's competitors are actually one
population that comes to mind here but
we're strict in calories to the extreme
Alexandra's noting can do some really
serious damage to our body especially
for us women this is a young beautiful
woman I am so worried about her future
reproductive health and fertility and
the risk of hypothalamic amenorrhea
which i've done a whole video on so you
can check it out right here and you
don't even have to be underweight in
order to be at risk
in fact decreasing daily calories by
even four hundred and seventy calories
has been linked to dramatic changes in
our hormones and health even if you're
still a normal weight
unfortunately most research and also
society at large is more concerned with
obesity but eating disorders is actually
the biggest killer of any psychiatric
illness the mortality rate associated
with anorexia is twelve times higher
than the death rate of all causes of
death for females between the ages of 15
and 24 why are we not talking more about
this finally I also want to note that
constant weight cycling has actually
been shown to be way more harmful to
health than having excess weight so the
up down pattern of severe weight loss
and gain
can and is likely doing a lot more
damage than Alexander realizes okay so
what do I recommend well I would never
suggest that Alexander is suffering from
disordered eating or even pushing that
agenda on her followers I'm sure that's
not her intention I do see some red
flags here that I would urge her to work
out with a therapist doctor and
dietitian I don't know anything about
her blood work or health status in
general I'm not her dietitian but if she
walked into my office I would want a
full workup to make sure that her
reproductive and metabolic health was on
track before this level of restriction
has any long-term effects if it hasn't
already I'd also like to point out that
her language is like really fat phobic
dangerously misguided and disrespectful
in general so I really do hope that as a
person with a large platform but she can
reevaluate how she sees others and
herself and ultimately get to a better
place in her relationship with food
before I close off I just want to of
course remind you to please keep the
comments respectful and constructive as
always with my science and SAS I'm all
about analyzing the recommendations and
the dietary approach I'm not for tearing
people the individual apart I don't want
to see any bullying any trolling on her
channel so please please please keep it
clean keep it respectful on that note I
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below if there are other
youtubers videos diets kind of what I
eat in the days that you want me to
review subscribe to the channel and I
will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
[Music]